okay first who would you trust in this
cast to keep a secret in real life and
the character in real life
Jaden Michael Shannon you think you
think Michael Shannon's got a mouth yes
[Laughter]
no Jaden for sure okay go with Daniel I
think okay yeah it's so strange and also
intimidating nobody would ask him anyway
so spill it I suspect foul play in all
the other rooms the pairs they grabbed
hands they look to each other's eyes and
they were like no and you guys who do
you think in the cast would be the first
to crack under pressure and the
interrogation I mean me I got a bad
poker face maybe I wouldn't like openly
crack like you would see right through
me the other said you're too nice they
said he's got such a kind heart he
wouldn't be able to be to be deceitful I
just feel like I would start sweat well
I think I'll be terrible too I blush all
the time so I don't I don't I don't
throw why but I blush you can good puke
is going great I think it's under
control now the scene where you have a
moment on to your face what was that
is there like a vegetable soup yeah I
think yeah before when we all got a
little because I think outside we were
even like putting in our mouths and you
know trying it out yeah
that was ejected like which consistence
is gonna get farther unstick to Chris's
face best yeah did you feel extra bad
like this face actually that's that
whole scene in the library is that the
library or yeah that was the very last
three four days of the whole show so by
then he's been so nasty to me throughout
the whole film that I was so excited
yeah it was hard for me to see the dogs
being mean to you because I love my
favorite part of social media huh yes
your pup Dodger it's fun there were such
sweet dogs and they hated you you have
to well they didn't they they wanted
their toys you know the way you get me a
jump on you is before each take you have
their toys you know I got you know you
get them all fired up and they're
vibrating and then you put the toys in
your pocket and they yell action and
then they come flying at you looking for
their toys these toys they give me food
my hair dog food and saliva like oh man
it was so cold that then they were
freeze
they've been leaking me all the way
you're a pretty lucky lady this year
sitting next to this guy and then the
next roles with Ben Affleck I mean yeah
what's that all can I say what is that
like what's that what what's the
pressures of that next role oh the one
I'm cheating water yeah deep what um um
it's pretty exciting it's I don't think
I've ever done anything like it and it's
a genre that I haven't also be in it
like haven't played anything like that
I'm with Adrian line who's the master of
the world that genre and I love Ben and
if everything is going well but it's too
soon to know to you and all the guys who
it needs a bit dude who's brought it out
as an export yeah you see he's a monster
yeah and Chris Disney Plus is going not
so everywhere
and so everyone in the internet wants to
know if there's a possibility to old
Captain America and the Falcon in Winter
Soldier if there's any more in you no
probably not yeah I mean it's it was
really tough to say good night
well there was a million ways that whole
tenure with Marvel could have gone wrong
and it didn't and so to stick the
landing so well they would be ashamed to
kind of revisit unless there was
something very unique and we felt the
need to reveal so for now it just feels
like let's just let's be content with
how well it ended no I love that okay
one thing I skipped what's your favorite
thing about being a dog dad everything I
think um I think I love a dog dad I
don't know what it is why do I love dogs
I like waking up to loved up so you love
dads I love dog dads no I love dogs
but then when a guy is a dog dad it like
just weeks you know I think it actually
unlocks a little bit as I imagine having
children will I really want kids to but
I think once you have that the weird
little door unlocks inside you this new
level of empathy and having a dog that
you just love and sympathize in a weird
way that type of empathy permeates so
many other aspects of your life
specifically with dogs but with human as
well it's it dogs are just so good it's
so pure and it just kind of you know you
you feel lucky if in any way it rubs off
your dogs
yes well this was a little unsure very
small and Roger is huge and I think he
felt intimidated so he kept him you know
yeah like out of his face but Elvis is
really cute
whereas Oh is he out here
[Music]